welcome
we're back
the first
official
h3 podcast in person
wow
the masked mandate has gone down
yesterday
we are in the studio mask list
vaccinated
uh vaccination
uh the first this is the first in studio
interview we've done in a year
today's episode is sponsored by canva
and me undies of course today
uh we are very honored to have with us
uh a special guest whose first ever
on camera
interview or at length interview how
would you describe it
any interview either at all
bella porch
tick tock
phenomenon
musician phenomenon
had recently your debut
this is an amazing detail okay
debut song build a [ __ ]
most viewed debut song in the history of
youtube did you know that either what
yeah no i didn't know that yes
the most
i know it's it's quite a
it's quite an accomplishment i've got
the stats
number one on the global and us youtube
video chart biggest debut ever for new
artists with over 75 million views in
the first day wow
the power manifestation eh yeah
tell me about tell me about uh how
you're feeling in life tell me about
where you are in life how are you doing
um
i feel like this is like
this last year starting last year i was
i was the happiest
yeah yeah
and i think
like removing like toxic people out of
my life a lot like i stopped talking to
people that i didn't like and
yeah i think that
that made me
feel better
and it helped like my manifestations
like
i have this rule when i'm manifesting
something is that you don't tell other
people your your manifestations so that
they don't put negative energy into it
the evil eye that's what we call it or
that's what the israelis are the middle
eastern scholars you know about the evil
eye i've heard about it yet
we gotta we should have got an evil eye
for about
they have these eyes it's like a hand
like this with the eye yeah i've seen
this meant to stop the everyone hating
it's happening just because i always had
it i don't
oh no
it's to stop the haters essentially
cooper believe in it but
like thousands of years ago people were
like stop the haters bro
talk to their hand
but
that is so amazing oh my god i'm still
shocked from that i mean yeah i feel
like i kind of got to know you around
the time that the song was coming out so
i almost feel like
even more excited for you because i saw
you going through the
song coming out
yeah i mean you you had dinner at our
house right before it came out yeah and
um
you let us preview the video
and i think we were both like oh damn
this is a hit for sure thank you did you
okay so now that you've now that you've
manifested can you say what you tried to
manifest or can you not talk about it
because it's like it's happened yeah i
can talk about it so tell me about your
ma what you manifested for yourself um i
just wanted my song to go well i didn't
really manifest oh i wanted to be like
you know like i want a certain view
view
on youtube or anything like that i just
wanted it to do well and i wanted to see
i wanted people to see that i i can be a
good artist like because you know people
are like oh she's just a tick talker
it's just another tick tocker song you
know and
i feel like
people
people think like tick tock is a cringe
app and you can't really start a musical
career from that app but
no like
you can actually start a music career
anywhere you just do it right and
just put like your passion into it
it'll work out so if you go back to like
let's say when you were a kid did you
manifest back then when did you first
start manifesting um i i only started
manifesting last year actually oh i
thought this was like a big part of who
you are oh it's funny because it um i
don't know anything about manifestation
um beginning of last year i downloaded
tiktok
and the first video was a manifestation
talk or whatever oh what
yeah so that was my first video and i
was like oh this is interesting and then
it was basically a video talking about
oh you should start manifesting and this
is i better start with this thing that
should work for you
yeah so what is manifesting as you
understand it um it's basically just
um wishing or believing that
what you want is gonna happen
yeah do you ha is there is it more
complicated or is there like more steps
or process like do you have to like
visualize it do you have to like like is
there a process to manifesting something
um uh mine's very simple i just write
three things on like my white like i
have a white board in front of my bed
and i see it first thing in the morning
and last thing before i go to bed at
night so it's just like three things and
when one of those three things are
done like if it came true i just put
another one in
kind of a great idea though yeah because
it's like keeps your mind focused
on like these specific goals
makes sense
yeah that we kind of got to talk about
it when we were
um just the two of us and i was saying
like i feel like my take on
manifestation is that
what it really is is like focus like
when you focus on something you're going
to get it done if you're focused and you
you really want to do it you can do it
so also what's interesting too is like i
feel like a lot of times i'm working and
i'm stuck in the motion stuff but you
don't i don't really ever have like
clearly defined goals
which is what kind of helps you like you
said focus i must start manifesting bro
like i know for both of us when we had
this like idea of the podcast
we had such a we had such a clear idea
we knew exactly what we wanted and same
with teddy fresh like
we had this exact i
visualized simple idea that was really
easy to focus on
and then it just kind of happened
so what meant what like manifestations
have you taken off the whiteboard if i
can ask
um well
the
[Music]
yeah and then of course my first music
video and my first song
anything tick-tock related um yeah i
actually started manifesting and then
because of tick-tock and
that's where i started doing like the
three things
like the three manifestations how did
you by the way i uh speaking of your
music video before we move on too far
from build a [ __ ] sam will you bring
something and we built something for you
you built something well
not built but we definitely paid
something
we made something
i think you'll like it
sam is going to bring it in and you tell
us how we did sam thank you so much
did we do good this is so cool what the
wait how alfredo is just sam made that
fight exactly like what i was wearing on
the music video i know yes um sam did
that by hand i'm definitely like framing
this i'm not sure yeah
i'm glad we did good this doesn't go in
like my other
collection this is like a special
thank you guys by the way um
you know people may not know ela was
almost in build a [ __ ] i know oh yeah
he almost made the cut yeah
yeah that was like we're almost a build
up [ __ ]
with peace and love
um yeah i feel like it was just kind of
like unfortunate that
we almost like we just got to know each
other we didn't even meet yet in person
and um he asked me if i could come and
then i really wanted to but it was so
hard it was like a saturday when we were
alone with theodore and i would have had
to like kind of leave you alone for the
whole day
and lately it's theater is a lot oh yeah
so
it don't work out but um maybe in the
future
[Laughter]
i would look good in those tights too
you know um
what was your so you wrote that song
build a [ __ ]
what was kind of like uh is that
something you felt a lot of pressure of
people like the expectation for you to
be a certain way
um yeah i always grew up getting like
bullied from
like in school i grew up getting bullied
and i was always made fun of the way i
looked so why
that's so hard to yeah
no because my natural hair is really
curly
really
well people make fun of having curly
hair i didn't realize it
oh because everyone has straight hair
and everything yeah so like the the
standards over there is like different
like it's wow yeah you have to have like
really pale skin and like straight hair
and yeah so it's very different
i'm
i
got bullied because of my hair i didn't
know that you would get you could get
bullied yeah for having curly hair like
i said i'd be i'd be murdered
yeah you ever think about letting your
curly hair go
um a few times i did a tick tock with
like my natural curly hair and people
were like oh wow you should leave it
that way but i'm like it's just so hard
to like maintain it like it is you have
to put a lot of products yeah and like
me putting on this pigtail every day is
so much easier than like
dude i
i don't know i hate having curly hair
personally it's such a pain in the ass
because you can have a good day but when
you don't it's like what do you do with
the hair i feel like i'd have more bad
hair days when i when i just let my
curls go so what was it like for you i
mean i i want to ask you about like kind
of your upbringing
you grew up in the philippines
yeah and then at what so first of all
what was growing up in the philippines
like for you
um it was very different
because i grew up in the farm
and i took care of like
farm animals
goats sheeps cows we had plenty and
chickens
i also grew up with like a lot of dogs
and cats oh really it was like over 20.
so was that like
was that what your
your parents did for work is there like
farmers uh no i think my
my stepdad just loved animals
oh wow yeah so he bought like a
a huge land and decided to build a house
in the middle of that land and decided
to just
start
well
uh farm animals
how long did you live in the philippines
before you left um i left when i was
like 14 going home oh wow okay birthday
yeah so i was i was still in my teenage
years so you live with your
stepdad you said and and your mom
yeah um so i was adopted when i was
three
before i was adopted i was actually
living with my grandma and it was like
in the slums like we were very poor
so yeah
so you live with you grew up kind of in
a poor especially poor place yeah in the
philippines with your grandma did you
ever know your biological parents no and
i feel like i i'm scared to know and i
don't want to know because i feel like
meeting them would be just really
awkward
do you always wonder about that some
people i guess choose to like go and
look for their
biological parents but
yeah it seems like
i don't know if i would want to do that
yes i'm sure the emotion is so
complicated yeah i mean i i can't
empathize but i'm sure that
do you think about them ever or is that
something that's kind of you don't even
think about on a day-to-day basis
i don't really think about it yeah
because i
i was really young i don't even remember
if i
saw them or yeah
so do you remember like your grandma do
you talk to your grandma still back in
the philippines um she actually passed
away oh i'm sorry last year so
but yeah i used to talk to her
super sweet
so you
so you live with your grandma and then
you are adopted
you live with this family on the farm
and you lived there until you were 13.
and so or 14 p.m tell me about your i'm
just curious you worked on a farm like
what was your daily schedule
it was
very hard actually because i have to
wake up at 4 00.
every morning
4 a.m
i do oh actually 4 a.m would be late
sometimes i have to wake up at 3 if i
want to get to school in time because in
the philippines school starts at like 6
30. oh my god yeah
so i have to be able to finish all the
chores so i'd be sweeping the yard like
picking up dog [ __ ]
tons of dog shots yeah i'd be cleaning
up the cat cat house because we had a
cat house and i'd be sweeping goat poop
the goat pen just a lot of cleaning up
[ __ ] yeah and i have to
clean up real good because if i don't
then my stepdad would
um get mad at me and he'd be like oh
you're not eating breakfast if you don't
get this done wow so yeah that sounds
like
like i think bordering on abusive
yeah i didn't actually realize that
until i got to the states that i was
going through that
to me was normal
and yeah it was
so you would wake up at 3 a.m
clean a bunch of [ __ ] and then like
how did how would your stepdad decide if
you did a good job or not um he usually
just checks the yard and you just see if
he sees like a poop in the ground you
don't eat breakfast yeah sometimes i
don't eat breakfast sometimes he just
like
uh slap me or
you know jesus yeah
and your stepmom was she like protective
of you or was she also
she was she wasn't really
abusive but she was i felt like she
could have you know said something about
it um yeah but she was very silent about
it
jeez
and like my nickname was like stupid
[ __ ] growing up
yeah that was my wife
at home it's hard because in the
philippines like whatever whatever
happens in your neighbors like house you
have to mind your own business like it's
none of your business
so
it's hard when i tell people like what's
going on in the house and nobody seems
to give like give a [ __ ] so you tried
asking for help from people yeah at
school and then i realized like nobody
gives a [ __ ] like i'd go to i went to
school one time with a swollen hand on
my right hand and it was like bleeding
and i tried to like stop the bleeding
before i got to school but it was really
bad and
um my teacher was asking me why am i so
like slow at writing that day because
yeah my hands are swollen and i can't
write with my right hand so i had to
write with my left hand and she was just
like okay just hurry the [ __ ] up and i'm
like okay like nobody gives a [ __ ] no
questions so yeah so the culture there
is very much mind your business yeah
don't get involved in other people's
stuff yeah
whoa
so
did you have did you have like siblings
on the on the growing up there yeah
um did they were they also getting the
same treatment um no my two
sisters they're they're treated way
differently
you have two sisters yeah older sisters
i'm the youngest and i also have an
older brother which he's here right now
you guys met him
was he or well i
won't involve him you're two older
sisters were like not treated the same
way yeah they were they had like a
special treatment they didn't really had
to clean poop
like that all they did was really like
maybe clean up inside the house but they
never actually cleaned outside why is
that why do you think they they targeted
you does that [ __ ] with your head i
don't know i always thought maybe
because me and my brother were like the
younger siblings so we were you're doing
like the dirty work
you know your brother got the treatment
too yeah
that's why we're like super close
it's like cinderella dude yeah yeah
that's not my brother you're literally
like cinderella
yeah it's pretty tough
it was like that the whole time growing
up in the philippines
did you resent your siblings who were
like treated well
um i always thought it wasn't fair but i
mean i couldn't really do anything about
it they were also like
bullying me and probably
yeah
golly they always got like the nice
things and i would get like the handover
like
here's my old bag or like
yeah and that's also why i got bullied
in school because i would go to school
with like holes in my shoes and like
people make fun of you yeah because
you're getting treated like [ __ ] at home
one time i got so embarrassed because um
my stepdad decided that i shouldn't my
brother and i shouldn't be showering
before we go to school we should shower
at night
so cleaning up like poop
like that of course i'm gonna like smell
but i asked him like can we shower in
the morning inside and he's like no
you don't have time god yeah
do your work eat breakfast go to school
what's wrong with that you ever think
about that like what is wrong with him
it sounds like he's a deeply disturbed
person he
he
recently said that he he was diagnosed
with ptsd because he was in the army
okay for like 20 years and
that was his excuse but i felt like
i don't know
i felt like
i mean i have ptsd and i don't go around
and hurt people you know or take
advantage of like
people
so
is there some part of you now that
you've become successful
[Music]
where you're like [ __ ] these people bro
like they they were treating me like
[ __ ] now i bet they [ __ ] wish that we
were they were good to me there's got to
be like
a little taste of like [ __ ] them yeah so
they've been like reaching out to me and
like oh we should yeah sooner me
and it's funny because they think that
when i go and meet them
they think i'll change my mind and be
like oh yeah like
all good yeah nice to see you um
yeah it's very hard for them to accept
what happened in the past like they
can't accept it you think in in their
minds they are like oh wasn't that bad
yeah and um
the way they apologize to me is like i'm
sorry that you feel that way um
it was
that made me feel so angry and i'm like
why would you say something like that
like
yeah so they why were they i'm just
confused like they adopted you were they
it's almost like they adopted you just
to like have a little servant did you
ever feel like that it's like we got
this person to work the farm and do the
bare minimum yeah yeah actually the
abuse didn't start when they adopted me
like it was good for like up until i was
six
yeah and when i was seven that's when it
started
when like we got all the
animals in the farm
basically but before that my life my
life was normal like i was still
i was still like given like a good
treatment like we would go to the mall
and yeah spend time like a family but
i don't know everything started changing
once we started getting like
farm animals once we started planting
trees i don't know but you ever think
about why
um like why would all of a sudden
i felt like he was just waiting for that
moment to like
buy a
big like land
build like
a house and have a farm
and i feel like he was just waiting for
that moment to like
be
that person
did he do any work on the farm
he sits in his room
like six days a week but yeah like he
would only come out of his room
for like an hour in the weekend oh wow
yeah
so deeply withdrawn and yeah if
if he went out it means he's checking
like me and my brother's work so we
would be responsible for like cutting
the grass
by hand
by hand
oh that's just stuff
that's just sometimes the grass would be
like taller than me
because back then i was like seven yeah
yeah and i i don't know i was always
scared of snakes but i don't yeah me and
my brother would just cut the grass
just with like shears a sickle oh a
sickle
[Laughter]
not many people here have sickle
experience
that is kind of yeah i get to play with
it too and um
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's your dad so what is your dad
doing in his room all day dude um he's
stuck with his computer i don't really
know what he does on the computer a lot
but
yeah
just on the computer yeah
and the ac
it'd be super hot in the philippines
like it would be like 95 degrees out so
he's hoarding the ac yeah
his room was the only place in the house
i had ac
oh my god there was like seven rooms and
that was the only room that had ac is it
a very misogynistic culture us back then
growing up or was it just he was a dick
uh
i don't know
i still don't know why he acted that way
but i felt like he just put his anger
out to like
me
and my brother
and
so you okay so
it sounds like just a horrible i mean
that that sounds really horrible and
then so you're spending your time year
after year
with this family and then at 14
what happens how do you
how do you escape that situation yeah so
my stepdad had to get bypass surgery
and there was nobody in the philippines
that was willing to do it
and so he had to fly over to
texas to get it done and
after that when he got the bypass
surgery um the doctor told him that he
can't go back to the philippines because
it would be
it'll be bad for him he'll have like
health problems and there wouldn't be
doctors to
take care of him
when complications happen
and during that time when he was gone i
was like so [ __ ] happy wow
yeah
like how long was he gone for
months like three months and so when
he's gone were you still picking up dog
[ __ ] were you like yeah yeah i was still
responsible there you go but
you could shower in the morning yeah
tell me about what tell me about the
experience of him being gone it was it
was fun i get to watch tv i get to sit
on the couch because i wasn't i wasn't
allowed to sit in the couch
yeah so me and my brother would be
watching movies and we would be sitting
in the floor
oh you were not allowed to even sit on
the couch even if there was space on the
couch yeah that i mean the couch would
be empty and i and your siblings were
allowed to sit on the couch yeah the i
mean they could that's whatever the [ __ ]
yeah so it's just you and your brother
and that is
second class yeah second class in the
house yeah and so i i was happy because
i get to like watch tv and i felt like a
normal human being yeah and i couldn't
even
in the house there was this rule where
you can't speak
the native our native language so we
were only allowed to speak english so
that my stepdad would understand every
single thing we're talking about wait
your step that doesn't speak the native
language no he's um he's white oh he's
american yeah he's american i didn't
understand that detail yeah so your
stepdad is an american living in the
philippines yeah he decided to retire in
the philippines no
wow
yeah and the wife the mom
uh
i think they met in saudi arabia when he
was stationed there um so your stepmom
is
filipino is filipino
oh so they got they met when he was
serving
and then he moved to the philippines
yeah to be with her
they don't have any biological children
uh no
huh
wow
what the [ __ ] yeah it's a really every
time i tell them all right but me and my
brother me and my brother were talking
about him but like this is like a
[ __ ] book like
literally
you are literally cinderella
yeah
dude it's crazy the parallels to
cinderella they have the the older
siblings who get all the good treatment
and then you have the younger sibling
who sits in the basement has to clean
gets all the shitty clothes it's
literally cinderella and then you leave
the [ __ ] coop
you get the you get the glass slippers
and all that [ __ ] i know it's crazy what
the hell
so you're so okay so your dad or your
stepdad who's american
he goes he's gravely ill he goes back to
america for surgery and the doctor's
like you can't go back
so he stays there is he still here oh
yeah
so what's going on back in the
philippines uh my two sisters just live
there now
and your stepmom um she's she's so he
just abandoned his family is is it like
that no it's not a man like they still
like take care like send money over
there to have the house taken care of
wait who sends money
my my parent my my step parents oh so
okay your step parents are here yeah
because my two sisters are living in the
philippines got it and what is their
relationship like your step parents
what's their really like yeah do they
love each other or are they
i think they do they do love each other
like they rarely fought
are they like like are they like psychos
i mean i don't want to be disrespectful
i don't know what to say but like how
would you describe them i don't know
they seem close when i was
growing up and i was going through like
abuse they seemed really close but do
you think they bonded over like treating
you guys like
i don't think so i feel like
she was just scared to speak up
because she didn't she didn't work or
anything so he he made all the money you
know
and
i mean he was retired so
what does he do
or what was his work like that
no um he was getting retirement
oh he was like a
ex-serviceman on a pension yeah i he
served like 20 years so he did like the
full years
and okay so interesting so they moved
back to the states you're 14 you're like
this is amazing i feel like a normal
human being so what what happens next um
he said that he has to take the family
and the
to the states oh so he brought you
and your brother
just you two oh yeah because my two
older sisters were too old too
what do you mean he has to
um because
my
like he's gonna be alone if he doesn't
and he's he's responsible for us though
like okay so legally because he adopted
you guys you're too young he has to
bring you guys yeah
and my older sisters you have to be
18 i think at the time to be
sent to the to the states like to
immigrate
um
so my sisters were too old for that
wow so you and your brother
come over and then you're living with
your step parents again
where are you guys living um first we
went to san francisco lived with my aunt
and you didn't even live with them
what you did not live with your step
parents oh we were living with them with
your at your aunt's house yeah got it
and i liked it because he couldn't touch
me or my brother
because
my aunt was there and it wasn't the same
situation yeah people in amer people in
america the culture is different they
care about yeah or they they don't mind
getting involved if they see a child
being abused yeah but like
my aunt would notice that we
were like robots like we would literally
sit like this and not talk
it was only like yes sir yes
wow like
yeah so
we were always scared around him and i
would always flinch whenever
he's around this is your dad's sister
your mom or yeah your dad's sister uh
it's like a
i call her aunt but it's in the
philippines if your mom your mama's
cousin's was like
um yeah it's like a cousin okay so your
dad's cousin no my mom like oh your mom
yes because your mom is filipino but she
has a relative in san francisco yeah
she's also filipino oh wow okay yeah
so did your did your aunt at any point
ever be like hit up your dad like what
is going on here um no
well she's filipino so they're like um
oh so it wasn't the american like yeah
it wasn't the american
but did she ever talk to you guys like
what's going on oh no
yeah she just kind of like uh did any
adult ever intervene and ask like are
you guys okay what's going on here um
no
not really
um
when i was living in texas
the neighbors would like hear like my
stepdad yelling at me and stuff like
that and
they would just
yeah they would just hear that almost
every day and i would be taking out the
trash and the lady would just be like
just let me know and you need you know
you need someone they were worried about
you yeah they were they were worried so
yeah that was like i think that was the
first time i felt how did that feel to
be acknowledged by someone even in that
small way i was very like emotional
about it because i'm like wow someone
actually cared here wow yeah
so
it's crazy
and did you ever like go to her or was
it just the acknowledgement um
uh i was scared to like reach out to
people
yeah
i still had that mindset like
i'm scared he might like i don't know do
something
right yeah i think that's that's kind of
typical an abusive relationship right
yeah and you just basically just learn
to deal with it until you take get the
opportunity to leave
and yeah i was just waiting
so you were in san francisco you moved
there so when did so yeah yeah so san
francisco for a few months it was like
two months and then i
went to
fresno and that's where i went to high
school
yeah and that's where i graduated too
so you spent your whole high school
years in fresno um it was like a year oh
just a year yeah and how was that it was
good it was good it was good i mean i
was a loner i had one friend
and so i graduated
when i was 16
and i was like 15 at the time when i was
um
going to like my senior year and so
people would always ask me like are you
are you in this class like you look
really like are you sure you're not a
sophomore freshman
and i'm like no this is my class like
i'm a senior and
yeah because you look younger yeah and
yeah it's
i liked it because it was a way like
school i always liked school because it
was a way of me
not being at home yeah
and it was like an escape was there a
culture in shock
yeah
definitely a culture shock well because
you described the home life in the
philippines where you're not allowed to
sit on the couch you're not allowed to
watch movies i'm sure you didn't do a
lot of things you probably didn't call
like like what's some notable things
that you could do in the united states
that you weren't allowed to do or didn't
have access to in the philippines i mean
even in the states i wasn't allowed to
like hang out or go out
or anything like that but i mean
he changed a few rules like oh yeah you
can sit on the couch now wow what a
genius
but i wasn't
i was basically not allowed to go hang
out with friends after school or
anything like that i was i never went to
the mall you go to a movie
movie theater you go to like out to eat
yeah um with my brother when we were out
looking for like jobs or something that
was mean
it's time to go hang out you never went
to like a roller skate or an arcade or
no out with friends no
that's that never like i never had a
childhood basically
damn that is just
yeah and that's why like um my my
managers like arianna and daddy they're
like wow there's so many things you
haven't done
and yeah they're just like taking me to
like these places
well experiencing new things for the
first time well when you came over to
eat well a month ago i don't remember
but you had never had italian food
yeah i mean
i never had real italian food okay real
well you said you did pizza
you were asking pizza's italian food i
was like well yeah technically it is
yeah
how was it
it was really good we had to uh we had
to get them again for another oh you
used them again
okay listen i'm gonna throw it to a
quick break and we'll pick up right
where we are when we come right back
i
love canva pro it's an easy to use
design platform that has everything you
need to design like a pro whether you're
a professional designer or just getting
started canva pro can help boost you and
your team's productivity and creativity
it's quick easy and affordable way to
design whatever you need
no matter what you're creating and
sharing canva pro has everything you
need in one place
including over 75 million premium photos
videos audios and graphics plus canva
pro comes with time saving tools that
simplify and speed up the creative
process you get it all in one place with
the canva pro subscription here's what i
love about the canva pro
it's like
for photo editing but they include all
these tools of the photos and the videos
and the audio templates templates so
it's like
you don't really need to be a pro to get
this professional looking product it's
very easy and it's great if you're
trying to
make any kind of image you know maybe
you've used it what do you what do you
like to use it for oh i love canva i use
it for the behind the scenes thumbnails
i've used it for instagram post and like
you said it's really quick and easy to
use the app is awesome as well does it
make you feel like a pro oh yeah
definitely oh yeah i'm in the big
leagues when i'm using cameras that's
right
what's your favorite feature
um i like that it already has templates
built in and you could swap them out and
see different styles really easily it's
like the it's like you're in the future
can you control it with your mind uh no
but working on that working yeah we're
getting there look
there's no idea too big or too small
for canva pro
designed like a pro with camber pro
right now you can get a free 45-day
extended trial when you use my promo
code so go to canva.com
h3 to get your free 45 day extended
trial that's c a n v a dot m e slash h3
canva dot me slash h3
mandy's changed my life
i'm just telling you right now
he was pregnant and i can say me undies
did that
because and let me explain
because traditional underwear just
doesn't give the respect
that my privates deserve really the air
to breathe but also the support i think
it helped i think it makes a difference
and i'm fat i'm girthy so i like
it's not the fertility treatments no
it's the underwear for sure well you
know this is my for me undies is my
fertility treatment
you do yours i do mine but you know i'm
fat too so i'm always pulling my
underwear to the max that's why i like
my undies because it's soft it's
flexible it's breathable you know
summer's coming in hot and me undies
it's breathable it's soft and you can
soak up the sun and that sweat coming
from your crotch
with a mix of classic colors and
adventurous prints it's perfect for
summer express yourself in your own way
because me undies believes that comfort
is about more than what's touching your
skin it's about feeling comfortable in
your skin hello
yeah i love honestly i started wearing
me undies i didn't know about them um
until about a year or two ago and that's
it bro it's just
oh have they been before i've lost track
of time they've been sponsored for four
years a year or two ago
i didn't realize we were doing the show
for so long
well the day they walked into my live is
the day that all the other underwear
walked out of my life
it's designed to be the softest thing
you've ever worn me undies are energized
by creativity and made for
self-expression and it's available in
all sizes from extra small to 4xl hook
me up with that 4xl please
mandy's has countless styles and prints
to choose from so your buns can always
have fun and meundies has a great offer
for our listeners for any first time
purchase you get 15 percent off and free
shipping me undies also has their
problem free philosophy if you're not
100 satisfied with any of their products
for any reason at all
you get a refund
you get an exchange are they gonna ask
any questions of you no they wouldn't
dream of it no questions asked no
caveats so to get fifty percent off your
first order and free shipping go to
mandy's dot com slash hp that's me
undies dot com
slash h3
welcome back thank you all thank you
bella so you so when did you move to
texas
um after i graduated from high school
okay yeah and you went with your family
again yeah why is he moving around so
much
um i don't really know to be honest i
didn't really i couldn't really ask any
questions
so like i said it was only like yes no
and if you have a reason don't say
anything like
yeah crazy
i can't really there was i never
actually had
a genuine conversation with him or any
conversation even to this day
yeah i mean i tried
um so
when i first had my therapist and i
talked to her about everything she told
me oh you should talk to your stepdad
and
see what he tells you like tell him
everything how you felt about your
childhood and stuff like that
and i did and
all he said was good luck
that's all that was his response that
was his response and
what does he mean by that even because i
told them like oh like i
have ptsd and like i'm so depressed and
i'm still traumatized about everything
that happened when i was like a kid and
i just wish you you know
you know that and
because he never apologized about it
you said good luck yeah
the hell does that even mean tell them
how i felt and he said good luck it's
like
okay are you glad you told him or you
like i wish i'd even do that um
i'm glad that i told him
because i felt like it
um because i was keeping it inside like
i never actually talked to him before
and
me and it wasn't even like talking to
him it was a message
i i yeah i messaged him on facebook
because i don't yeah i don't even want
to talk to him because okay so this this
happened probably when you're already on
your own i was i was in the navy yeah
and he just said good luck yeah he said
good luck what does that mean what do
you think he means by that i have no
idea it it just shows that he doesn't
give a [ __ ]
good luck
i wonder god he must have had usually
when people are abusive like that they
had you know
a [ __ ] up upbringing too
i wonder if he was just like
it was almost like good luck i had to
[ __ ] deal with it
so now you have yeah he never really
mentioned anything about his life yeah i
was wondering if you ever had any
insight into him at all during your time
living with him
to understand him why he did all this
[ __ ] he did yeah it was hard because he
wasn't even close to like his relatives
or anything like
i only met one
person from his family and it was his
cousin i think
but yeah
he wasn't really close to any of his
family um
yeah so
it was
i never
really felt a connection
when i'm growing up and
every time like i see
kids with their parents and like i get
so emotional because it makes me so sad
i'm like i never had that
yeah
and i'm getting emotional i mean i must
be
so
weird to grow up like that without
having any connection at home yeah no
like safe space for you
did you feel like you had a safe space
growing up at all um
i mean
no not really like my room i wasn't even
allowed in my room up until it's like
um after i do all my how do you do this
i don't know it's i don't even know
how someone could do that and there's no
like checkups because you guys were
adopted there's no one that comes and
checks yeah
it's if the conditions are good it's
kind of sad because in the philippines
there's like no
wha what was it here child
yeah they don't really have that
yeah so
just good luck yeah i wish
i wish they had that and
still it's 20 21 and if they still don't
have that and
it'll help so much if
they had something like that because i'm
pretty sure there's a lot of
um abuse going on in a lot of
i've never even honestly heard anything
like that in my life
just like the the psychological views of
not allowing you to sit on a couch or be
in your room it's just like
or do anything that a normal kid does
yeah
yeah yeah
it's amazing
it's amazing everything you've you've
accomplished despite all that
thank you yeah
so when you were you were in that you
were in texas
and then at what point did you
say
you know [ __ ] this
i know you joined the army was that to
get away from the situation with your
dad so my brother decided to join the
navy
and
that um
he was like you so when you join the
military you have to wait like a certain
time to get into it
what do you mean so there's like a
waiting time so you
you enlist and they're like okay so in
three months you you
yeah
so
um when we were in texas he was
basically just waiting for
and did your step that know that he had
enrolled and was he trying to get him to
stop or he was he fine with it no he was
fine with it
yeah
and
so
me
um
of course i didn't know what else i
would do except for college or join the
military so
yeah i decided to join the navy
and
yeah
at first i was scared but i was like
this is like the only way this is my
only way out and i have to do it and
your stepdad your stepmom didn't give
they didn't care they're like that this
is a good path for you funny because um
the day i left for boot camp um
my
my my parents couldn't even drive me to
the
wrong to the yeah
um
the last
words from my stepdad was
don't ever come back here this is not
your home
really yeah
yeah
and so he said if you fail boot camp
this
you're not coming back here
yeah
so
he just basically said and your stepmom
co-signed that she was like
all good i think she would she didn't
really said goodbye to me i don't know
if she was sad or something but
she was just like okay
but that is just be that is just so
cruel but i can see you probably don't
even consider them your family really
just like these weird people that you
live with growing up
yeah
gosh
yeah and like did that hurt or were you
like [ __ ] these people
that hurt
yeah it definitely hurt um
because i i was still like thinking like
maybe you know maybe they'll change you
know but now i'm just like you know [ __ ]
it i don't care but
back when i was younger i still
i still had to
had a thought in my mind like maybe
they'll change maybe they'll love me as
a daughter because yeah
ugh
that hurts my
heart
did you always feel like you weren't
doing something right so like they
weren't loving you because
i mean
i don't know like i was a kid so yeah i
don't really understand everything
yeah
what a [ __ ]
fish
that is just so cruel man
so you are like taking like an uber or
something or getting a ride with
somebody it was my recruiter who your
recruiter had to come back
and he told you that on the way out
um yeah
well my recruiter was waiting outside
and were you like crying on the way
there or were you just like processing
it yeah i was i was emotional but i was
just quiet
you know god i want it and then the
chutzpah of these guys so who reached
out to you now like hey let's get
together daughter
um
they both did but your dad so your
stepdad who you've never talked to
reached out to you yeah so he doesn't
like talk to me talk to me but
um she was like oh yeah he said that he
wants you know to meet you
yeah
we both miss you
oh really
yeah
and so what are your thoughts like when
did they message you i'm curious like
when and the your career path did they
decide like oh we want to reunite now
um
so when i was in the navy like i didn't
i don't really talk to them
because but i was still being nice you
know like i would say hi to them once in
a while
and that was about it but
i think
the start of like my
tick tock like
fame the starting of that that's when
they actually wanted to like see me and
stuff
so you must have did you feel like at
the time like oh they're they're
obviously just reaching out to me
because they know i'm making money
um
i feel like that
yeah
and what was your thought when you got
that message for them like what did you
feel
uh
well
i go through therapy like a lot
my
my doctors just basically tell me like
if it feels right then go meet them but
if you're still scared then don't
because
that would be bad you know
um
i feel like i've i'm still scared to
meet them like i mean they don't deserve
any in my opinion i'm not therapist but
they don't deserve [ __ ] from you
now they want your affection bro i mean
[ __ ] them forever yeah and
it's it's just hard because i'm never
close to them and now that they're like
you know
reaching out and be like oh let's hang
like and it's obvious just because they
probably want something from you
maybe yeah
but
tread
[Laughter]
oh my god
and so do they keep reaching out to you
because you said at the beginning you've
got more and more successful you've got
now this super hit mega hit music video
do you keep hearing from them i don't
respond to them but they keep reaching
out
he doesn't but she does
yeah
just saying she misses you and stuff
yeah do you believe that
kind of oh
yeah interesting
yeah
i mean she wasn't really mean to me
growing up but
she did
call me stupid [ __ ] as a nickname so
no she didn't do anything to protect you
yeah she also didn't protect me
it's just so embarrassing because i'd
i'd be outside and it would be in public
and i don't know where they would just
call me stupid [ __ ] in english yeah
what yeah
i thought maybe it was like some
filipino word that translated they
literally just called you stupid [ __ ]
yes did they call your brother or any of
their siblings anything like that um
they call them the um
the f
word and i don't want to say it
but it's
like the gay slur yeah what really yeah
oh my god dude these people are
yeah so that was his nickname and
this was my name and your two older
siblings no demeaning nickname they they
got called
by their names
it was different for them when did you
start doing therapy in the navy
oh yeah
um a lot of people realize that i don't
talk or anything so they're like they're
people are concerned there's nothing
wrong with her
and i'm very anxious and i flinch every
time like someone tries to grab
something from a cabinet i would
literally like uh
wow so you you but see your stepdad was
hitting you quite a bit if you're
flinching away from people
he was hitting me a lot
yeah
and so now you're in the navy and people
are like this this girl is struggling
socially
and they put you in some kind of navy
therapy
yeah i was a navy doctor so they get to
talk to you about
you know
anything that's your doctor shocked when
you're like
like that must have been like what you
said what happened to you
yeah
they're they always feel very sorry for
me like
like i'm sorry you have to go through
that like
you know it's and what was it like for
you realizing like how [ __ ] up your
childhood was because like you're so far
from normal yeah cause you said you had
mentioned that you thought it was normal
yeah i i mean
when i was like a little bit younger
i thought it was normal but as
like i was getting a little older that's
when
you start to yeah see the world yeah i
think when i was at 13 that's when i
realized was there a specific moment
where you saw a different family or
someone and you're like oh my situation
is not like that yeah
because i see in school a lot
um
that
my classmates would have their parents
you know supporting them
and their the talent shows and stuff
like that because i would i would i
would join the talent shows a lot for
singing
and
yeah i
the
people who are joining the competition
their parents would always be there to
support them and stuff and i would be
the only one who who doesn't yeah so you
were like wow all these parents are here
supporting
all their parents are here and my
parents are the only one not here
so clearly my situation is not the
typical one
yeah
damn
and i wasn't even allowed to do that
like i wasn't allowed to join
competitions or anything you did that in
secret the talent yeah um i remember one
time and me and my brother used
still laugh laugh about it um
there was one time i was late because i
joined a singing competition
and i got in so much trouble
but um i mean i came up with a golden
medal
yeah and um
i
yeah i got in so much trouble and i peed
my pants and um because i was so scared
of my stepdad
did he see the metal in your hand
um i didn't want to show it but i felt
like that would just
make him even more mad
to see you succeeding in some way
and they didn't really care but i
actually
got 36 medals from you've got 46.
spelling bees like mostly singing and
art
so you had this secret life where you
were doing all these amazing things yeah
in school school was like my escape even
if i was getting bullied i didn't give a
[ __ ] because
i'd rather be bullied like in school
than be like beating up and
go through like
[ __ ] at home
so dude
that's so you had it you had this
passion for singing going all the way
back yeah hmm when did you discover that
passion for yourself because you i mean
i've seen you on tick tock before you
released this video and it was all very
obvious that you are a very talented
singer
thank you so i was wondering like
yeah um so
i started singing when i was seven
but i didn't really know i could sing up
until my brother told me something like
oh you're not singing
i'm like oh am i
because um i grew up with mulan i
remember
the movie
and the song reflection
so you were just saying what the disney
film yeah
and that song was like everywhere and in
the philippines that's like
one of the go-to karaoke songs too like
reflection because um it was sang by
leia salonga she's like a filipino
singer
and yeah
and i was singing that song and my
brothers you still have those medals you
want in school
yeah it's in the philippines
and it's what it's in the it's in my
room in the philippines oh
yeah
we got to get those first yeah yeah i i
am back
um
not really but i mean i told my sisters
to if they could yeah if they could send
my old stuff you still have beef with
your sisters
your older siblings i've forgiven them
because they were kids too probably
right at the time yeah right
i mean if your parents are calling you
these horrible names they're just like
yeah [ __ ] them it's the adults that you
i don't know yeah i don't really blame
them for that's good i think they did
would you just bulldoze that whole house
if you could oh yeah i would [ __ ]
love to destroy that [ __ ] i was
actually thinking about that
music video oh my gosh
you said man and that house is huge it
has like seven rooms and really yeah
you should do this right i just want to
[ __ ] it up like i would i want you to do
that and like i feel like oh my brother
my brother he said that they're trying
to give it to him like like good and he
doesn't even want it so you guys can
just bulldoze it
yeah he's like i don't want it but okay
dude you remember it just reminded me
there's a scene i think in force gump
where she does that jenny
she goes back to the old house she grew
up in and just and forrest gump like
destroyed it am i remembering that
correctly
i don't remember that movie but the
movies
[Laughter]
dude you got to destroy that house i
want that for you
i mean i mean my sisters are still
living there so get him a new place
you're crushing it
just be like listen listen guys i gotta
i gotta destroy this house
so back in the philippines you're
you must be like
a mega
star right people know about your
success there i'm assuming they know
about it yeah oh really yeah my huh my
school bullies actually reach out
oh my gosh like when you come back let
us know we'll throw a party for
you like how does that feel
how odd
because you when you were there everyone
was treating you like [ __ ]
now everyone wants to be your friend
that's odd yeah we were just i thought
we were just playing probably they're
saying no
yeah
how does it feel though would you
consider doing something like that um
yeah i actually want to go back to the
philippines not
like
at the old house that i used to live in
but i would want to visit the
philippines because i don't know i love
the philippines i feel like it's
a huge part of me of course it's my home
yeah yeah
and
yeah it's
i love philippines
yeah
what would you say
i know we've talked about a lot of the
negative aspects of of your experience
in the philippines what are things that
you like about the philippines
uh people the people are always happy
and
that's what i noticed
like they don't they wouldn't know what
the [ __ ] going on they'd be just
smiling like
hey what's up
but um
strangers like they're always nice to
strangers
or like visitors and
yeah if you're lost they could always
tell you where to go and
just as long as you're not being abused
by your parents yeah and if you
if you're a foreigner and you know
english like
that's they have really good english in
the philippines oh really yeah
why is that they
um so in schools it's taught it's time
yeah it's like a priority to know
english
and yeah that's the same oh dana's
saying it was a u.s colony apparently
yeah
um okay so maybe i don't know dan said
that
yeah it's also like if you know english
it means you're very educated so it's
like a status yeah yeah
so you joined the navy
at 18 i'm presuming
about 17 17. oh can you join i didn't
know you could under 17. you just got a
waiver signed and they were like yes
yeah
and
yeah it was it was fun i had so much
freedom i feel like
ironic yeah um
i just remember in boot camp everybody
was like crying because they missed
their mom and wow
and i was over there and i was like the
youngest and i was the tiniest and i'm
like
this is the best thing ever parties like
what we're in the room we're all
sleeping together this is like my first
time that is so a sleepover i mean
that's just so ironic that you went to
the army to gain your freedom
which is like the kind of it's even like
you know
it's almost like a metaphor for losing
for losing your freedom right yeah and
your individuality
but there you kind of gained that which
kind of just speaks to how [ __ ] up
things were for you did you make friends
there in the army or the navy yeah
yeah
like even the people i go went to boot
camp with i'm so
really close
with them and in boot camp my first day
in boot camp um
it was so weird i don't know what to
expect and everybody was just like you
know
like uh we don't know what's gonna
happen and [ __ ] like that but as soon as
we get there there's like people yelling
at our faces and then next thing you
know
someone says um who's a soprano
and oh they asked about singing who's a
soprano and this literally that's all
the question he asked and everybody was
like confused like what the [ __ ] does he
mean and i
i raised my hand i'm like i wasn't right
now
and the people around me were confused
because like they don't know what a
soprano is and i'm like oh i i was in
choir so
i it's basically like if you join choir
you know what a soprano alto and stuff
like that and
yeah
and he was like okay everybody that
raised their hands um let's go to
another room and
and they took us in another room and he
basically said okay so this division you
guys are going to be
a musical division what we'll be
performing in graduate boot camp
graduations
since when does the
navy have a musical department um i mean
it's for
um
boot camp like graduation like ceremony
so when someone
you know those people that hold the flag
right yeah so
that's basically us people
it was like almost like
god that's just amazing how you know
immediately you're making friends you're
singing yeah
there's other people that was good at
singing with me and
i met people that knew how to play the
trumpet
and like the
the people that were spinning the rifles
and stuff pretty cool to watch them
but wow it was fun because six days of
the week we go through like rough
training and stuff
and on the seventh day like every sunday
we just get to practice for like a boot
camp graduation so it was fun it was
just like a whole day of me singing
um memorizing songs and stuff so
so you must have been like maybe
were you kind of like happy for the
first time there in the navy yeah i was
really really happy wow
and um
there were days where people would
receive a
mail like letters and stuff
and i i i would only get one it's from
my brother
and everybody's like wow you got a
letter i'm like yeah it's for my brother
all of them are just like they have like
a whole box of like hoodies and i have a
[ __ ] letter but yeah it's funny
your brother yeah he sent me a letter
what a guy how does it work do you go
back home every
something like every month or something
or no you just go boot camp is like
three months
and you basically you can't do anything
you can't go
you
you can't you can't even go like on
facebook or anything like
no computer anything like that just
training yeah and then after that then
you get to
take leave and
meet your family so what did you do
during leave
um i didn't take it you just stayed on
the base yeah on
under graduation so i had to perform you
know like choir and stuff
everybody's parents were like
waiting for the same story like the
talent shows yeah
and
it was time for us to leave and i was
like [ __ ] i don't have anybody to hang
out with so it was that that day after
graduation you get to go on dinner with
your family or your friends that visit
you but i didn't have anybody so one of
my good friends decided oh yeah
you can come with us
she was super sweet here so you know
yeah her mom was super sweet i love her
yeah
is that chuff always being reminded of
that like when you see all the friends
and family or are you just kind of used
to it yeah by now i'm used to it but
back then i was like i get really like
it's very uncomfortable i mean to say
the least right yeah
it's very
very sad yeah oh yeah but
yeah
so you graduate from boot camp
and then you you take like i don't know
what's called but i think you like sign
a contract with the navy and do like a
service with them yeah so i signed a
four-year contract with the navy and i
i did my full-time
um
yeah i'm so happy because like the navy
taught me a lot of things
like you could be like the tiniest
person in the room and you could still
do
you could still carry like the biggest
[ __ ] submachine guns but um yeah
did you carry some machine guns yeah
what was your job in the navy um
i was an aviation ordinance so i had to
take care of
basically any weapons that go into an
aircraft
wow weapons expert
so wait what was your job with the
weapons exactly um we
take them apart and then we clean them
big ass like helicopter guns yeah
and then we put them back together and
then we make sure they work for when the
air crew or pilot decide to use them
and
yeah i also did like took care of like
rockets and
that's crazy
you ever nervous working around that
kind of stuff for the first time i was
really nervous because i'm like oh my
gosh how how if i drop this like i don't
want to like a big ass rocket or
something yeah
and they used to make fun of me because
like half of the things i would carry is
like
so like
um
they would always make fun of me because
i would
always carry this uh you guys know like
a gal 21 it's like a machine gun okay
let me pull up a picture i want to see
what that looks like it's called a gal
21. yeah how do you spell it uh gau
21.
and it's like minigun taller than me so
this was something that was um
on a helicopter like yeah
yeah so they would they would let me
carry this and this is like 90 pounds
it's like why they do that to you
they're just like [ __ ] it you're
everyone's pulls their weight around
here
were you on a boat yeah
how was that and it was hard at first i
had like motion sickness and stuff oh
i'd be like carrying this guys i would
put this in my shoulder and like go
through like a flight of stairs and
the boat would be moving
and yeah
it taught me a lot of
courage oh god that's hard work man and
it will be raining so sometimes it will
be really slippery wow [ __ ] yeah it's
giving me like
the memories yeah i'm getting flashbacks
what kind of aircraft were you on
um i was in the
aircraft aircraft carrier whoa
carrier it was it's pretty big
um you'd never actually get lost in it i
thought it
i thought you'd get lost in it but it's
very intuitive like like going around
how long do you spend at sea like um six
months
yeah
does that get claustrophobic or um no
because it was also fun because we get
to hit ports um i went to australia cool
yeah and so you can get off enjoy it how
long do you get out and like if you go
to melbourne or something how long three
to four days any of the countries that
you visited do you kind of like have a
response for
i think
singapore was my favorite one
yeah
i don't know it's so pretty
there's literally no trash anywhere
they're like a wealthy country right
yeah they have like oil or something i
don't know why i don't know but i just
know you're not allowed to chew gum or
something like that wait is that the
country where the were they the prime
minister
like murders drug dealers or is that the
philippines i think that's the
philippines yeah
wait is he he's the one that yeah he
says he wants to kill drug dealers and
drug users yeah wow that's a philippines
um
yeah in singapore it's so pretty and
people are so nice
and yeah that's my favorite one
so was there like
mingling did you have like
romantic connections on the boat in the
navy because like i'm just wondering
what was kind of like your dating life
coming out of it it's funny because um
i
got dumped while i was in deployment
and
i mean i was in a relationship with them
before like we went on deployment and
we're not on like the same ship so
you're in a relationship with someone in
texas
uh no no no no i never had a
relationship
um
ever until i joined the navy oh oh i see
oh okay so sorry mr said so you were out
he was stayed and you were out on the
boat and he dumped you oh i see yeah so
that was your first relationship yeah
and
i guess like
he cheated on me and that's he wanted to
move on to the next girls
i mean
at least he broke up with me
that's true but yeah i could say
something nice about it yeah i just
remember like
getting an email you know email because
email breakup oh i guess that's is that
the only way there's no phone signals we
can't use our phone so it was on email
like
i'm sorry i can't do this anymore i'm
waiting with you damn
email me back why are you so cruel why
is that so mean
don't ever email me back
and so
it's so
i mean this
it's it's so dramatic because i walk out
and then i go to the flight deck and all
you see is the ocean and then you see
like a dolphin
you know jump out of the freaking water
and then there's the sunset and then i'm
just like sad
it's so dramatic
and like
but i don't know
it's funny
how how is it like um
kind of
forming relationships coming out of the
kind of upbringing you've been through
do you have a hard time connecting to
people or boys in general i didn't
really know anything about getting into
a relationship here's a funny story
actually um
so in a school um so after boot camp you
go to a school it's a training where
they
tell you like um about the aircraft and
stuff like that
and i went through that training in
florida pensacola
and so
i
that time i had bought my first phone
and it's like my first ever phone and
that's when i started like you know like
meeting new people and um
there was this one guy that got my
number and he said oh we should go on a
date
you know let me take you out on a
cute date and i'm like okay sure let's
go
and we ate on this fancy like seafood
place and then
we
got back home and then
after that um
because um i was staying inside base
and
the girls and the guys are not supposed
to
like
be together like it's
yeah we're like in separate buildings so
he's like
when he was taking me back to my my
building he's like okay
i'll text you tomorrow or later you know
i'll see you again and i said bye
and the next day he didn't he didn't
text me back
so that wasn't
and
i was crying to my room
and i told her i think my boyfriend
broke up with oh
my god and then she's like wait you've
only been here we've only been here for
like a week or something and how the
[ __ ] do you have a boyfriend now
and i told her this story like yeah
um he texted me we went on a date and he
never answered me today so that means he
broke up with me right
and he's like first off he didn't even
ask you if you could be his girlfriend
that's not how it works wow yeah so i
was like oh so they have to ask you that
because like in the philippines it's
different it's different like if you if
you're out seeing on a date that means
you guys are already together oh really
yeah so you thought he was asking you
let's be together yeah i really thought
that was a dinner
i thought it was him asking me oh okay
like okay i guess we're together wow
it's been a slow learn or there's been a
learning curve that was my first i mean
that i don't really
say that was my first boyfriend now
because you know
but yeah yeah yeah
that was my experience
and so like
do you remember like your first kiss was
that a big deal for you
like all these small moments and
it was terrible like yeah my first kiss
um he smoked a lot
of cigarettes yeah and
the taste of my mother you didn't expect
that um
yeah i don't like it
so was that your boyfriend or just a
different guy you wanted um i think i
was drunk with some friends on it
when i kissed the dude in the bar
but yeah at a bar yeah
wow
so there's still things like
you feel like there's still things
you're learning i mean there's got to be
so much stuff like there's got to be
there's just stuff in everyday life
you're like oh [ __ ] i didn't know that
i just found out about this oh that's
yeah i would literally ask my friends
all the time like how does it work like
how does this work do you remember any
specific ones where you're like
oh that's how it works it's like so
obvious to everyone else like
straightening my hair i remember asking
my roommate how to straighten my hair
because i had never straightened my hair
before and i had really like curly hair
and
yeah she basically taught me how to put
on makeup and
yeah
wow
and we went out everywhere we go so she
was showing me like the malls and
there's them all blow your mind
did the mall blow your mind oh yeah
i was like what
and then
yeah it was it was so much fun because
i never really got to experience that
before
you make
like decent amount of money when you're
in the navy um yeah they pay us pretty
good like we don't have to pay for like
housing or food so
yeah you have money to play around with
which you probably never had him any
money so yeah thousand dollars views
could it might as well be a million
bucks right yeah yeah
but yeah
it was really fun
and i would always ask for
one thing i got made fun of is like i
would always ask permission to do
anything
of like your commander or your cheat or
whatever you call it so like oh can i
can i go to the mall this weekend or can
i go play bowling this weekend like
dude you don't have to ask us
your officers were getting annoyed like
stop asking us for permission yeah
because like um you know i grew up
having to ask permission for a simple
water
so really yeah that controlling yeah
that controlling so going to the
restroom
yeah basically so
i wasn't used to just having freedom
and i was like wow this is this is
amazing the navy is like freedom
well everybody's like oh i gotta take
leave to go see my family like i gotta
take leave to go here and there i'm like
why do you have to go there if you have
everything like you could go
anywhere yeah
yeah so i was happy
so what's the first time so you're in
the navy for four years
and uh i guess
at the end of four years they probably
you had an option to like renew your
contract or to go do something so what
did you decide um i decided to leave i
mean i don't really have an option
because um my mental health was
getting really bad in the military
and so my doctors decided
we don't think you should
renew your contract i think you should
just
take a break
what kind of symptoms were you expecting
um i was really depressed like very
depressed and like uh my ptsd was
getting worse
yeah
so you were like and what like withdrawn
were you like suicidal at that point
really yeah i
yeah
very suicidal really yeah
that to the point that i had to always
have a roommate with me
to watch over me
yeah
you wanted to like you had like visions
of wanting to hurt yourself or like what
what was it like for you um
yeah i was thinking about it and also i
actually attempted
you did yeah you attempted once while
you were in the army yes in the navy and
i had to be in a psych ward for like
five days and
yeah it was
after that um
it gave me a lot of like
in
put like a sense to me like people care
about me because
when i was in the cycle
like all the people i worked with and
all my friends were like visiting me
every single day and wow yeah they cared
about me
so yeah that made me realize a lot of
things it's interesting when you talk
about the navy to me because it's almost
like
a story of two lives it's like one of
freedom and this joy and thrill of
having but then on the other side this
really
uh
dark depression yeah
um were those two things kind of always
living side by side for you
um yeah i was
i felt like happiness was like
very
very short and then i go back home and
i'm alone in my room and it's just very
dark
yeah and so you you finish your service
at the navy
basically on the recommendation of your
therapist yeah were you wanting to
extend
um
part of me yes because i didn't know
what else what else to do right
where do you know i saved that money but
i was like that's probably gonna last me
like another year and that's it it must
be scary though to be like okay i gotta
leave the navy i have nowhere to go i
have no idea what i'm gonna do so what
so what happens
um they
the navy actually like helps you get
into college you know or get a job
yeah so i was in the process of doing
that but
then again my my doctors
were telling me to like um don't push
yourself too much
well what did they want you to do um
they want me to take a break but what
does that mean just sit down i mean they
actually want to put me in those homes
where a lot of um i forgot what it's
called but it's like a program
where they take care of uh
people that are struggling with their
mental health
it's like it's like a
it's like putting you in a psych ward
but with more freedom right like yeah
wow
so they were really concerned about you
yeah they were really concerned about me
because i'm about to
get out of the navy yeah right
yeah and i didn't really have
family like you know that i want to go
back home to and my my brother he's
still in the military so i can't go just
live with him you know
so i'm basically
by myself and so they cared about me a
lot
and yeah i was just gonna say like
despite feeling so bad it must have felt
nice to know that these people actually
yeah wanted to take care of you
yeah
were your parents expecting you to come
back after you were done no yeah it's
they never checked they knew yeah they
they knew i wasn't
yeah
and so well what happened you know um so
i said okay i'm gonna go take a break
and
i got out of the military and i decided
to live with my friend who's still in
the military so i was living with him
and so
he was
like
he was like a really close friend of
mine because i worked with him and so he
knows like
how
my mental state is and so he cared about
me so he's like okay you can
stay
at my house and
we he has like other roommates too and
yeah i made really good friends
and where were you living at the time i
was in my uh
i was in hawaii
in waianae oh you were in hawaii yeah so
yeah i was stationed there for like my
last year
in the navy and
it was really great i'm so grateful that
they stationed me there
because it's amazing it's paradise
so so you ended up living with your
friends
and for how long were you there did you
end up working or just taking it easy
what was your life like um so
my friends were very supportive so like
every weekend we will go on hikes and
stuff
yeah so they took care of me and then
what did you do all week
basically slept
played video games
i played a lot of fortnite
and was that your first experience with
video games because this is kind of
something that was never accessible to
you um
minecraft was my first one i was in the
military and everybody was playing
minecraft really yeah
dude everybody and unbeatable
should i play minecraft i've never
played minecraft yeah i think you should
okay i've honestly been thinking i think
you'd love it sorry i'm sorry to make
this about me but i've been thinking
about starting a minecraft series just
because i don't know anything about it
and if he's totally i think it'll be fun
yeah
dan's saying plea with theodore i think
he's a little young for that dan
two-year-old playing minecraft
you guys start young
so you're playing minecraft fortnite
what was it like playing a lot of tech
into and yeah
okay let's go yeah here's a funny story
um so on deployment they would
um set up these gaming tournaments just
to boost morale because you know if
you're in the middle of the ocean and
everybody just gets depressed you know
and so
yeah they would set up those tournaments
and i would always win how did you get
so good at tekken um
well i was when i was growing up my
brother
had a playstation 2
and so the only games we had was tekken
prince of persia
um what a
mortal combat i think but um i didn't
really play that growing up but um
i mainly played tekken so you got really
crazy good at tekken and this
the thing about
um that too is we didn't have like a
a card to save like the the data and
stuff so if you want to unlock a
character you'll have to
every time every single time
so yeah
so that's how i got good at it so you
were at tekken boot camp at home you're
using your neck and all day yeah i mean
not really like i was
i would sneak in to like
to play video games because i wasn't
really allowed you know
but every chance i get like when my
parents are gone like when they're going
grocery shopping that's got to get you
some respect in the navy though
right yeah i would always win
using panda
and everybody's like there's no [ __ ]
way she's got to be cheating like
definitely cause panda is like a little
slow oh you know yeah but i feel like
he's he's
the strongest i got one of my only
fights over tekken
when i was a kid you know paul he's got
this move where he sweeps and then
elsbows
so i had to i had a friend from around
the corner who came over and we just
played tekken at home and i used to just
always hit him with the sweep
the sweeping elbow spam that oh yeah
just sweep an elbow all day and he
couldn't deal with it
and one time he got so angry he threw
the controller down and put me in a
headlock like just pure anger and
violence because i kept owning him with
my sweeping elbow and then my dog at the
time
[ __ ] was so badass just this little
dog a little bigger than alfredo jumps
up and
the minute he bites his
in a headlock and he left crying and i
was like
i love that dog so much
awesome
yeah tekken serious business
so you're living in this house
for how long are you living there oh for
months
a few months a few months
and is there ever how's your mental
health during this time in the house it
was
i would say it was the same but a little
better
because i didn't have to get stressed
like at work you know like i didn't
really have other
the stressors of having to do your daily
tasks yeah stuff yeah
so and so after a few months what
happens um i decided to move to another
place
maui
oh you moved to somewhere else yeah and
i went to maui and
it was great i thought i would like maui
because it was like less people and
people said it's like you know the
country of the countryside
and just more nature and stuff yeah i
wanted to
just start a new
life
and were you living by yourself uh my
friends oh okay so you guys all decided
to move there yeah well how did you end
up in l.a
yeah so
i downloaded tick-tock while you were in
maui
how long ago was this
uh like january last
year so it's been like a year and a half
yeah wow damn life comes at you fast
so a year and a half ago you're sitting
in maui you say you're seeing this tick
tock app
um are you hearing about it friends were
forcing me to get it because they
[ __ ]
every single day they would send me
these videos
and i didn't even have the
the app downloaded so when i click the
link it takes me to like something
browser yeah and then it would show me
the video and then they're like just
[ __ ] get the app dude
and then i decided okay let me download
it and
yeah i downloaded tiktok and
just watching videos got addicted to it
and then when did you decide like hey i
should try to make a video because
that's a big step right from consuming
yeah to actually making your own videos
so like
like uh i was talking about earlier like
the manifestation talk it was a lot in
my 4u page there was a lot of them in my
forum page
and so i was like oh
let me try it out and then i put uh go
viral on tiktok
oh wow
and how long did that take you
a few months
wow yeah i mean i didn't i didn't start
video like i didn't start my videos up
until like
january from marine mart like march
so
do you remember the first like tick tock
you made what were the kind of videos
you were making it wasn't me singing
and it got like a hundred views and i
decided to take it down oh wow
because i was like oh it didn't it's
been hours
oh nobody cares three comments like that
seems like a lot though right kind of
for a first post yeah that is that's
kind of bad
but i was like [ __ ] like i want to go
viral you felt embarrassed yeah so i
took it down and my friends were like
what the [ __ ] did you take it down it
was good i'm like because i got shy i
got anxious you know
okay so so when was the first one you
left up um
video game related one
yeah um it was
it was a me just lip syncing to an audio
and it was
me holding a controller in like a video
yeah and did people watch it yeah oh
they did yeah
so this was i think it had like 10k
views wow yeah did you consider that
viral i mean no as somebody who yeah
cause like i was aiming for like
millions millions that's viral yeah i
was aiming for millions so how long
before you got a million um when i did
my first face zoom video
and it was like the open up the save
[ __ ] got elected that was your first
viral one
yeah i got a million you got a million
views and then i decided to take it down
really because half of the comments were
really negative about what
about me like just your looks my face
my face zoom and then people get she's
like my makeup
i did that
pink um cheek
makeup look and
yeah people were just like talking [ __ ]
like
how the [ __ ] does this have a million
likes
yes
yeah and at the time you know i was very
new to like
creating content and
i took that personally so it broke my
heart and i was like damn people are
[ __ ] ruthless like mean
and then to the point that they were
making fun of my face and so i was like
okay i'm gonna take this down because
it's so negative wow yeah
and then i did it take you a while to be
like okay i want to keep posting yeah it
took me a day or two to realize you know
what i shouldn't give a [ __ ] you know
because that's what my friends told me
they're like dude you were in a navy you
should
you learn not to like you don't [ __ ]
give you know give a [ __ ] what other
people think you know just the internet
is so brutal man yeah
and i decided to make more content
and
did it immediately take off again or was
it like slow so slow yeah it was slow
actually when i when i had the m to the
b mm-hmm
i already had like half a million
followers that's a lot
that's not that much though consider how
much you grew from that one video really
yeah like a lot to me
well now she how many do you have you
have like 70 million yeah yeah
so
so you're you're growth after that
zero it's like yeah yeah you're right a
millionaire is like uh you're just like
you're a tick talker i mean half a
million people but
that video i have the stats here
i know if you know this hilo
it's the most liked
is it the most viewed also
um not viewed but the most
uh tick tock of all time
and that's chris so that was your next
viral hit
yeah so what was it like for you after
that one here look can i watch it and
probably not i'll get claimed oh i'll
mute it though [ __ ] it damn mute this
that's so interesting when i saw this i
was like oh she i figured you were
already super famous i didn't realize
that
50 million likes god damn dude
jesus christ
[Music]
[Laughter]
i think you noticed like there's a i had
a band-aid on my chin no
what yeah i had a banana oh yeah oh my
goodness oh my god i've never seen that
why did you have a pimple or something
yeah i had a before i wanted to hide
that i didn't notice yeah
yeah
it's funny because this
actually took me two hours
to get it right i believe we had like
100 drafts yeah i totally believe that i
mean it's like perfect yeah i told like
my roommates like shut the [ __ ] up i'm
trying to focus
get out of my room
but yeah so what was the growth like
after that one because that that video
was
wow yeah i mean i woke up and then i saw
that it blew up and i was like oh it'll
slow down and i'm gonna next day and
then next
i just remember seeing like a million
likes on the first day and i was like
that was the fastest
one that i uploaded that got a lot of
attention in the first day and then were
you reading the comments and or were you
no i learned not to you're like don't
even read yeah yeah i do
for the most part yeah i have this rule
like i can read the comments for the
first 10 minutes when i upload something
um yeah people are nice now because
people are nice yeah once it goes like
mega and i hate your water people start
eating yeah
that's a good rule
my rules i'll just read like the top
view on youtube as maybe it's different
i don't really look at tick tock
comments but on youtube i'll look at
like the top five which are generally
fans and nice people and like you can't
go any deeper than that god help you if
you do
so you got you had like a few million
and you said it just kept going up now
scott yeah how many views have like half
a billion or something yeah half yeah
great that's crazy crazy and i'm it's
still like the likes and the views are
still going because people keep
rechecking it like oh just checking like
how many likes it has now like
i think when people sign up for tick
tock they show it to them too
because if they haven't seen it they're
like oh here's this video
that everybody loves
yeah and so i was like wow my
manifestation happened really fast
you're really good at it
i don't you don't even have to think
about it i felt like
i don't know like i never even think
about it like i just see it on the piece
of paper and i just go on about my day
i'm gonna do i'm legit i think what i
really like about it is it forces me to
focus on specific goals
which i think is really important
[Music]
man
so now
you are
in
hawaii still your account is blowing up
are you starting to make money at any
point um no during that time the creator
fund wasn't a thing yet
god you would have made so much money
from that video yeah or maybe you still
do now
like at what point did the creator funk
come up
here i think it was a month after the m
to
came out when it came out you're like
[ __ ] yeah i just wish
[Laughter]
yeah so
um yeah i started making money from the
creator fund you know
and so
a month
for like the first month the mtw video
um blew up a lot of people reach out to
me they're like oh do you need a
management team like
just from that one video yeah just from
that one dude
and yeah so there was like a couple
you know and then that's where i met um
my managers now your current managers
yeah who you obviously are very close
with yeah they're they're they're family
to me yeah
and um
they're it's funny because
they messaged me from like a verified
account
and
the freaking
the what you call the profile picture
yeah it's like a cowboy and it's like a
crying face and i'm like oh my crap
and i asked my friend is this is this
sketchy like
why is this verified account with like a
few thousand followers
asking me if i need like you know
management and stuff like that they're
like
i mean just talk to them you google you
looked you researched about them a
little bit like how did that come to be
how did you decide on them amongst all
these other people interested
they were the only ones that didn't ask
to sign a contract
the first yeah the first day so that's
really smart of you dude they are they
were the only ones that were willing to
meet up with me before i signed any
papers
and we're the only ones willing enough
to like
you know like spend time with me and get
to know me more
and get to know them more
that's really smart of you i have to say
especially in like
being new to the industry and not
knowing much because a lot of the times
these blossoming
artists really get creamed by
bad management deals yeah i was scared
that that was gonna happen but yeah
that's actually how i so you asked uh
how did i get to l.a
and so my managers decided to fly me out
so did they come out to hawaii to meet
you um no
they flow you out to meet them oh cool
to l.a they paid for everything so that
thing that's a serious like gesture
and two weeks became eight months
oh you haven't gone you never went back
whoa
like you still have all your [ __ ] in
hawaii um i mean i had my friends um
yeah
it was only going to be a two-week thing
and then it became months so what
happened how does how did you decide to
end up staying here i mean
um
i did i decided to make a career and i i
was told like
i get to
pursue my dream
you know
to be an artist like i always wanted to
they're like we believe in you
your vision we want to support you yeah
and you're like [ __ ] it i'm not going
back let's do it manipulation time
and um it was
it was hard for like people to
take me seriously
at the time because all i did was make
faces
but um as soon as i
started putting out singing videos and
stuff
they're like oh
she she actually could sing like this is
very interesting did you oh was your
goal always to become a musi a musician
musical artist
yeah i mean in school they would ask me
what's your dream job and i'm like i'm
an art an artist and then i said i want
to be an artist but if it doesn't work
out a veterinarian a veterinarian
so
i think that's good for people to know
i feel like that's important important
kind of
note in your life is that the singing
passion is the thread throughout because
i think there's people that are like
you've mentioned you know they write you
they write people on tick tock and
youtube because let's be honest there's
a lot of people on social media who try
to become artists and it's like
it's clearly not their passion and
that's why it sucks
but it's interesting that from you from
the beginning it's always been about
singing
people always make fun of the way i say
singing
singing
what do i do i don't understand what i'm
saying right now i don't know people
make fun of me i knew that when i said
singing
i don't know how to not hit that g
running
run
run or no
yeah you're saying it right running but
it doesn't yeah but it doesn't have that
second g that's the problem
what's another word with the double g
banging banging
banging i have a problem with that i
just realized yeah
say banging banging okay
[Laughter]
wow what a ride so you
move out to la they help you find
housing and stuff because it's a big
city it's like
i was living in hotels for months yeah i
kind of noticed that i i was watching
your tick tock i was like why is she
living in a hotel yeah they're making
fun of me they're like oh is this a
different hotel nice new hotel like
every single video
yeah because it's it would be like
different settings like
for like every week i would be in a
different place so they figured oh wow
did they pay for that it's expensive no
i mean i was paying for it but and what
was your primary source of income just
the creator um creator fund and like
like promotions you started getting ad
offers and stuff through your agency or
through tick tock um just through my
management management that's awesome
probably some big ass deals where you're
like holy [ __ ] did that ever happen when
you got yeah you're like what they want
to pay me how much yeah
that's awesome yeah so crazy
so you're in l.a
what is it like um
gaining audience on tick tock like do
they get
invested in you
as a person
or is it just kind of like all these
viral moments where people don't really
know you or care about you
yeah um
i noticed that people were so curious
about
me because i never talked in my videos i
was yeah so they're like what is she
like like what's her personality and
recently i've been showing it more
and they're like oh wow like i people
that hated me on tiktok loved me on
youtube like they said they watched like
um they would watch like the podcast
with like um
100 thieves and stuff like that they say
i'm a complete different person from
like my
lip syncing videos kind of weird comment
don't you think because it's not it's
not like you're just it's not like
you're like yeah like
so much there for them to make a
judgment yeah
so
and
like i think my fans are also like
growing with me
because they don't even ask for face
zoom videos anymore
i noticed you stopped yeah why did you
stop doing the
videos that you kind of got popular for
i wanna
i wanna bring more attention to music
and recently i've been working with more
like
good music coming up so
you have
[Music]
this is such an incredible time i'm
trying to i'm trying to cover it
so you're in the hotel
and this was just eight months ago
and at what point do you start working
on
like build a [ __ ]
um it started like so after
i got signed to my label i think
sometime
before christmas or something like that
so the label came through your
management they're they're putting all
this together for you yeah
was that a button
[Laughter]
um yeah so after that i went to
my first
ever like recording session
and it was with um suburban
and i didn't know what to expect because
it's like my first time recording and
was that like a producer or something
yeah he's a producer and artist um
he
he didn't know what to expect from me
too because we never met before and all
he saw was my tic-tock video
so um
yeah he he told me he thought i was
gonna be really bad
oh that's what he feels like but um
i actually turned out really good and he
said that
he's very glad that i turned out to be
talented
so you guys shot that in december now
it's june it came out like last month
did it come out last month or this month
i mean we shot it like
october like november december like we
kept working on it and dude i can't
believe how fast it's moving for you you
came out here eight months ago you've
been working on this music video it just
came out it's like this non-stop
uh
climb
yeah
yeah i feel like everything's happening
so quickly it's gonna take it takes time
to acclimate
i mean we've had like you know in our
career
which has now been almost like a decade
it take it took me like five years i'd
say to even like acclimate to
to kind of what was going on in our
lives
do you feel like you have acclimated or
is it all just like a blur still
um
i feel like i'm just going
like
like going with the flow yeah
yeah i'm just like
i don't understand what's going on but
i'm gonna do it
yeah i just do do it like i
take the opportunity to do
things
and it's also taking me out of my
comfort zone
and yeah i'm just basically
challenging myself
do you so i'm assuming you're working on
like an album at this point uh an ep oh
an ep so like how many songs roughly
so you have one song are you going to be
having i'm assuming you have more songs
yes um yeah a lot of people ask me how
are you going to go
one song yeah
um yeah i'll have more songs for you yes
i'll have more songs wow before i go
over yeah when is that are there tickets
yeah september where can people buy
tickets um at the virgil's mania tour
is their website it's a website yeah
i'll put it in the description we'll get
it from you guys okay
is that crazy are people buying tickets
buying tickets and they probably think
um it's only one song so it's funny but
it'd be awesome though that'd be kind of
a great show three minutes
no um yeah i'm so excited because
i've only performed in like talent shows
now i get to
own song perform
it's crazy dan tells me we have 10
minutes so i'm gonna wrap it up here
um i do have some questions that i want
to ask you
um
i guess right out the back
um so you're in la you're working how's
your mental health these days how do you
feel you're doing um i see my therapist
like weekly so
yeah she helps me a lot and
it's a busy schedule so
i like it i like that yeah distraction
and
i always make sure i get lots of sleep
like
i take lots of naps so
how many hours you sleep i would sleep
like eight hours a day and still take a
nap like midday i love that
yeah
and so
are you medicated can i ask that um yeah
i take diloxatine so oh which one's that
i take lexapro
um
deloxetine i don't know i just take it
because it's prescribed to me
yeah alexa bro helped me a lot
i know that
yeah it helps me because i used to have
like a lot lots of nightmares and um
yeah
so kind of helps
you know yeah
that's good i'm glad you're taking care
of all that it's
been through a lot
any love life any interest um i don't
know i'm so busy right now
but so so how long has it been since
you've been in a relationship
um
a year
was this the guy that texts broke up
with you no it's a different guy yeah i
only had um two ex-boyfriends so one
that broke up with you and then this guy
yeah had that one hand
it was like oh like you're leaving the
military i guess we can't be too he's
he's in the military yeah and so since
then it's just been work work work work
i don't like it
i mean there's a lot of guys in my dms
you're an eligible bachelorette now i
mean what do you think about that
anything interesting in the dms
um i'm
i gotta meet the person in order for me
to like start like
you know but yeah
i don't wanna i don't like the the
thought of like dming someone
well i agree or responding to dms and be
like oh let's you know let's meet up
yeah
i feel like i i want to meet them like
if i'm in a party and then i meet them
and then they're like oh hi you know
yeah
yes
hmm well okay here here's something i
want to ask you because i think you're
going to have one and i know we're
running short on time
do you have any ghost stories or
supernatural experiences or alien
visitations or anything like that i'm in
the philippines yeah yeah
tell me yeah so um
i was like three at the time and my i
was living with my grandma
and
i remember
before she passed away um a couple yeah
a year ago she was telling me about like
um
how i used to be
playing hide and seek
by myself
and
i remember just like
playing with kids you know but in
reality like
we didn't have neighbors at the time and
i was basically just playing with myself
but that's spooky i still have a memory
of me actually playing hide and seek you
remember the kids yeah i remember the
kids like i don't remember what they
look like but i remember i was playing
with kids but when i told her this
before um yeah remember uh how are they
like how are the kids that i used to
play oh yeah and that's when she brought
it up we never had neighbors so i don't
know you know i mean you were playing
hide and seek by yourself but
she remembers you playing by yourself
yeah i play
hello that is pretty spooky
it's a good one yeah add that to the
book
the
playing with ghosts
this is like my go-to story when
people ask me about it because that's
literally my own that is good that's a
good one yeah
which so you said you're busy i assume
you were like what are you doing day to
day you're going to go to the studio
record right you're going to go record
more today
after this
yeah
amazing
well i have to say
uh first of all honored
that you came here for your first
interview
and i think you're such a fascinating
person and you're so upfront and open
and your story is
unbelievable incredible
and uh
i just wish the very best for you i mean
thank you thank you for having me like
this is crazy like
i always watch you guys oh you do
i don't know so and
this is crazy too like i'm adding this
to my special i'm so glad you like it
yeah yeah it's amazing what you're
accomplishing right now just uh keep
going thank you you feel super proud
yeah
yeah just keep i think you're right just
don't don't look back just keep grinding
just keep your head down keep grinding
take care of yourself too
you know
thank you
whatever that means take care of
yourself yeah yeah but i know you know
it's like yeah your mental health
but you're you know it's good you're
surrounded by good people i know that
yeah yeah yeah i'm very grateful that's
a good thing like i have a really good
management team and like my friends and
yeah your manager is a really nice guy
my brother's like an hour drive away
from me he's still like in the military
but he visits me like almost every
weekend so
i'm so happy
that's so important i think especially
in your position as you become more and
more famous and successful you become
it becomes harder to know who you can
trust and stuff so surrounding yourself
with people that
have you've known for from the beginning
is so important
it must be surreal for him what's yeah
yeah you always tell me pinch me because
i feel like i'm dreaming or something
because it's crazy
yeah we've been through like
a lot of [ __ ]
a lot of stuff
yeah
wow that was a wonderful conversation
yeah bella porch on tour going on tour
i'm gonna put the link in the
description
and uh boy that was a fantastic uh
conversation thanks for sharing it was
awesome and thank you guys um for
listening like it's
i tell this to like my friends and
they're always like in shock like what
and
yeah we would
talk about it for hours and like yeah
yeah there's just so many things
that's really unbelievable story it is
yeah well that's our show today
we'll see you guys on friday all the
best hopefully stay in touch i know you
and evelyn have been you guys went
shopping recently how was that you guys
were shopping again right now you guys
went to the gucci store yeah
it was fun
check out some furniture
oh yeah they have furniture did you know
that yeah
is it super it's got to be really
expensive gucci furniture yeah
very pricey
10 15. we were just looking yeah just
checking them out
[Laughter]
ela's a good person to shop with
yeah she helped me um buy uh my
sunglasses and oh yeah i wear them all
the time it's really cute yeah i love
them
all right guys see you on friday thank
you so much
[Music]
you